at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking this episode is brought to you
by helix sleep last year I focused on
dramatically improving a few things
surprise surprise
most notably the quality of my sleep
which seems to affect just about
everything this led me to revisit you
name it
my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix sleep helix has
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleeper cold sleeper or you like
plush you like firm with helix there's
no more guessing or confusion just go to
helix sleep calm forward-slash Tim take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life that is
their promise for couples helix can even
split the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they have
a 10 year warranty and you can test
drive your mattress for 100 nights
risk-free right now helix is offering up
to 125 dollars off of all mattress
orders so check it out get up to 125 off
at helix sleep comm forward slash Tim
that's helix sleep dot-com forward slash
Tim for 125 dollars off your mattress
order tickle ik helix sleep comm forward
slash Tim
this episode of the Tim Farriss shows
brought to you by athletic greens I get
us all the time if I could only take one
supplement what would it be
the answer is inevitably athletic greens
I view it as and a lot of you now view
it as all in one nutritional insurance I
recommended it way back in 2010 in the
4-hour body and I did not get paid to do
so I've been using it since before that
and I use it in a lot of different ways
I travel with it to avoid getting sick
or to help mitigate the likelihood of
getting sick I take it in the morning to
ensure optimal performance and overall
it covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
dose bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get for a limited time and extra
$79 in free product so check out the
details at athletic greens com forward
slash Tim again that's athletic greens
dot-com forward slash Tim for your free
travel pack with any purchase while
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show or it is
my job to deconstruct world-class
performers to tease out the thought
processes the best practices the
influences and so on
that you can hopefully copy and paste
into your own life in some fashion to
test out the toolkits of people who are
the best of what they do my guest this
episode is a return guest Josh Waitzkin
he was in fact the second ever guest in
episode two of this podcast we've known
each other a long time Josh Waitzkin is
author of the art of learning he is an
eighth time u.s. national chess champion
a two-time world champion Taichi push
hands and the first Brazilian Jujitsu
black belt under nine time world
champion marcelo garcia widely believed
to be the greatest grappler who has ever
lived at least in the world of BJJ for
the past 12 years maybe 13 maybe 14 now
josh has been channeling his passion for
the outer limits of the learning process
towards training elite mental performers
and
Business and Finance or the finance if
you prefer and to revolutionising the
education system through his nonprofit
foundation the art of learning project
josh is currently in the process of
taking on his fourth and fifth
disciplines paddle surfing and foiling
which we will discussed some length in
this episode josh is always a fantastic
a thought partner he is constantly
pushing back at anything that I say
which reflects sloppy thinking or
imprecise thinking or consensus thinking
and he's a lovely guy so without further
ado please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation with none other than Josh
Waitzkin
Joshua good day sir
Timbo good to see you yet again and
we've had a chance to spend a bunch of
time together and all sorts of questions
have come to mind that I've wanted to
ask you and all sorts of discussions
have come up over meals and wine and
cold plunges that I've wanted to explore
with you let's talk about if you're open
with open to rather starting here some
some recent explorations of learning and
specifically some insights related to
someone you introduced me to quite a few
years ago Maurice Ashley Yemen Maurice
it was a me as a dear friend and we
became very close when I was 11 years
old playing chess and between the ages
of around 11 and 2324 we studied chess
five six hours a week together sparred
together traveled around the world
competing together against one another
and as a team training partners and it
was actually really cool he came to
visit us a couple weeks ago and it was a
really unusual life opportunity because
Maurice and I haven't talked about chess
in about 20 years so imagine going it's
all in just deep dive with someone for
13 or 14 years in an art not talking
about that art for 20 years growing in
different directions and then coming
together and a lot of what we were
exploring were questions around for
example what were our assumptions or our
shared constructs
20 years ago things that we agreed to be
true that we now don't believe to be
true and for context I mean Maurice was
a high-level chess player oh yeah how
would you how would you for people who
don't know the chess world how would you
describe he's a stronger and master and
we I mean we grew up they kind of came
up the ranks together he was he's older
than me he's about I think 10 11 years
older than me and he's a beautiful soul
and we were I mean back in the day we
were just brothers very similar to my
relationship with Dan Caulfield that I
have today and in martial arts and now
foiling Maurice was my sparring partner
in in the chess world and I think that
they I think what you're referring to in
terms of what we were exploring was was
fascinating because I mean a lot of what
I think about today is the emptiness of
mental models or the the relativity the
non absolute nature of any kind of ideas
or constructs or networks of ideas that
we have things that we believe today
will likely see as somewhat flawed five
years from now and so I work on seeing
them as flawed today and seeing their
the holes in them and so what was really
interesting to explore with Maurice for
what were the things that we believed as
pretty strong chess players back in the
day that we just no longer believed to
be true individually and collectively
and what came up a lot came up what came
up for you well but what one of the the
direction of thought that I found most
interesting it's not just what were our
false constructs twenty years ago but
what are the common root structures to
my current constructs and my false
constructs twenty years ago I say so in
other words what did what do you now
disagree with in terms of beliefs you
held twenty years ago
that nonetheless sprouted from sort of
roots or seeds that current beliefs
share that I may or may not be present -
yeah no you may not and then part of the
challenge is to be present to them and
then examine their emptiness today
mm-hmm one of the interesting
differences between Maurice and me
twenty years ago is that when Murray
studied chests he was extremely
idealistic fanciful it's so much
somewhat to a fault competitively so
there were moments where for example
Maurice to be playing a beautiful chess
game and
he would make a mistake as we all do and
he would kind of lose interest in the
game because it's like the poetic
perfection or something of what he'd
been creating had been marred and and
his idealism was obviously so beautiful
to me but also was sometimes a little
bit a little bit frustrating when we
were training together and that
frustration you know we both learned
from and it was really an explorer so it
was an example that came to mind for me
where there was a moment I recall
viscerally when I was probably 22 years
old
we were studying a variation of the NIDA
of Sicilian and we saw a there was this
position that would come after three
incorrect decisions so in other words in
this complex opening that we were study
there would be three mistakes that we
made and led to this fascinating
position and maurice was like we should
study that position and I thought that
was completely impractical I was like
dude what are we gonna study this for
its imprecise all right we should spend
our time studying a position we might
actually see and it was an example of of
me feeling that maurice was being kind
of overly fanciful or idealistic in the
training in the moment of training and
Maurice just being fascinated by
something and seeing it would be cool
and interesting to learn from
potentially so in that moment I had a
lot of confidence that he was barking up
the wrong tree and when I think about
that now 20 years later I was absolutely
wrong I think that studying that
position so much of what learning is at
a high level to me today is conceptual
learning the Matic learning it's not
about anything local and so that
position had so much dynamism to it so
like the convergence of different kinds
of dimensions and it would we would have
learned so much from sitting we actually
did end up setting it we didn't learn
learn so much from it but when I think
about it today like that was a massive
blind spot for me so there was so then
how do i deconstruct that into a common
root structure today well I think that I
have if you look at the way my buddy Dan
and I studied martial arts together for
a lot of years we took on Tai Chi push
ends together starting in 2000 in
training camps for the 2002 and 2004
World Championships and then we
transitioned to Brazilian jiu-jitsu
reached high levels in that art and then
took on now we're taking on surfing and
foiling together really all in on
foiling and one of the differences
between the way Dan and I
learning is that I would argue that he's
a much more gifted athlete than me and
I'm much more of a deconstructive
learner than Dennis so I tend to deccan
early in the learning process around
something Alton the deconstructed down
to the component parts which might be
technical or often will be thematic and
then I'll internalize those component
parts and then I'm ready just to go all
in on chaos Dan likes to just throw
himself off a cliff and then he reaches
his technical clarity by just jumping
right into like the chaos and so we have
different paths to a similar place and
we've learned to navigate that together
so the interesting thing is that there's
a little bit of a of an identity or a
stiffness in my approach there so
there's something about the early stages
of learning a new part for example of
foiling for example we've recently
started dialing in to-- foiling whipping
on a jet ski whipping someone in on like
the lightest possible high-performance
foil board and riding big waves can you
describe for people who may not have
heard our last conversation together
what a foil board is so foiling is
you're on a surfboard and then beneath
the surfboard is a two and a half to
three foot mast which is sort of like a
big guillotine you know and then beneath
that as a wing which can be a big or
giant razor blade yes exactly it's a
really safe heart and the wing it wants
you're in a way of the wing is what
you're riding so the wing is interacting
with underwater way of energy so you get
lifted off the board is lifted off of
the surface of the water for the wings
in the water and you're standing on a
surface which is a few feet above the
water and it's crazy because it's
frictionless it's incredibly fast it's
so dynamic it's awesome I mean I've
never been more in love with an art my
life and the purpose if I am getting
this right of using a foil aside from
the different kinesthetic experience and
aesthetic experience is to be able to
move faster on bigger waves or to is is
that how foiling came about as a as a
technology well there's lots of yes I
guess maybe that's that's a part of what
came out I mean you're above the surface
chop so when it can be choppy weather
and your fear on a foil you're just
above it all so you're frictionless so
conditions that are Unser 'full or foil
able because the surf will be chattering
on all
surface texture in the foil is above it
I think that you know so much of how I
personally relate to it is it's
frictionless Ness I think of learning as
unobstructed self-expression so friction
is a form of obstruction and what's
fascinating is foiling you're you're
just it's such a powerful physical
embodiment of that principle and I know
we're gonna hop around both had a lot of
coffee but so we were talking about
these sort of labels and in
flexibilities we may come back to that
but one thing that is really impressed
me that you and Dan share in common is I
suppose you probably focus on this
perhaps more you correct me but the use
of technology and training to really
accumulate focused repetitions right so
for instance you have a foil board then
you have an e file right so so how would
you use an e flow so we we took on four
so the way I took on foiling was I got
an e foil and I spent about two months
flying around two thousand miles on flat
water so I learned foil dynamics just
first of all working on on flight on
with a motor Sony foil is a foil with a
prop on it with a lithium battery and
and I was flying in flat water at
between 15 and 25 miles an hour just
getting used to flight dynamics because
it's being on a foil board it's really
it's micro micro recalibration if you
back wait you fly up if your front
weight you go down if you overweight you
crash into the floor into the water or
fly or the if the wing comes out of the
water your your catapulting so I worked
on flight dynamics and I worked on break
Falls which is a hugely important part
of it which I don't see a lot of Foilers
do which is really training in the art
of falling which something the Dan and I
did of course for many many years in the
martial arts and it's not just learning
how to fall when you want to fall it's
actually turning a fall that's out of
control into a break fall so it's it's
really learning how to prepare for the
moments you haven't prepared for and and
being good at break falls opens like
when I took on one wheeling right which
is an electronic skateboard with
big wheel one wheel in the middle around
New York City you know I had a lot of
falls at 25 miles an hour into New York
City pavement and if you don't have a
break fall you're gonna get hurt but if
you do you can just roll out of it and
be fine so I think that being
comfortable falling it's a really
important principle I would say and we
could talk about designing the learning
process around principles as opposed to
around techniques so it's like the
technical arsenal of brake falls like it
would fall into the principle of just
being comfortable falling and then you
can take a lot more risk than you can
take otherwise because the fall will be
something that's part of your domain
well let's let's take an example of
practice that I've never heard anyone
else discuss maybe this is common
practice I suspect it is not but you've
achieved the world-class levels and
multiple arts that in and of itself is
very uncommon with foiling specifically
and we won't spend an hour talking about
only foiling but I think it's I want to
highlight for people that this is a
discussion of learning and principles
using the example of foiling using an E
foil to go through boils over and over
and over again is that principle based
is that technique and perhaps you could
you could just paint a picture of what a
Boyle is and why that why you chose to
practice in that way right okay so
zooming out for a moment the way I think
about taking on these arts it's
understanding what are the component
parts and doing lots of reps in them so
that you're comfortable with them then
putting them all together so my learning
process won't look great in the first
couple days or a couple weeks and I'm
not concerned about that and I think
that one of the interesting parts of it
is like people I think that a lot of
what's happening in surf culture or oil
cultures people have these Instagram
accounts and there are always posting
videos of what they're doing and they
have to look cool and so there's this
groupthink that I observe around what
looks cool
and what the micro culture will approve
of and so you can't really do things
outside of that and so for example going
through boils when you're on big wave
faces on a reef sometimes there's an
upwelling of water that that were like
you know if the water interacts with a
shallow spot or a ledge or a big
you'll have a boil that is just like a
big shooting up of water pressure in the
lungs like boiling water
it looks like boiling water and when the
wing hits that or when a court on piece
of a wing hits that foil wing you just
can get thrown so you have to learn to
absorb it so you have to learn how to
what was either weave around it weave
through the boils or absorb them and so
one of the things the e foil opened up
was the ability to to really seek out
boils and learn how to you know lowering
level little bit sooner at the top of
your wing when of your mast when you
enter it and then there's learning what
the boil does if you hit it if you hit
the wings straight on on the corners
lots of falling but for example putting
on a helmet putting on an impact vest
those things don't look cool on
Instagram and so you can't do those
things if you're gonna be posting on
Instagram every day right but if you're
living kind of a bizarre hermit life
like I guess I do and not doing that
kind of thing you guess I can confirm
you can look I mean embracing looking
absurd in certain moments is a very
interesting hack to what others might
not be sees taking advantage of in the
learning process and so I spent I mean I
went over hundreds and hundreds of oils
on the e-file and learned how to absorb
them and had incredible crashes but then
I learned how to dial in those crashes
and I learned how to hit the boils at
different speeds and absorb some times I
mean I got thrown off that mid thirties
miles an hour after then whipped me and
on a on a off of the jet ski on a four
pound foil board the other day and this
boil just erupted me and I went flying I
mean it's an ongoing process at
different speeds but but yeah I was just
gonna say I remember the first time we
spoke about this because it coincided
with a week later and we talked about
this me going to volunteer at something
called zendo at a a festival called
lightning in a bottle
which I wanted to attend specifically
not because I'm a concert or festival
goer but because it's effectively like a
mini Burning Man that skews to younger
ages and for people who don't know zendo
is a peer supported a harm reduction
volunteer outfit that helps people who
are going through difficult drug
experiences generally
or oftentimes psychedelic experiences
that do not require medical intervention
so there's medical triage for people who
have done something that could be
physiologically dangerous but otherwise
for me it was the equivalent of you
going through boils because if for
instance and I'm not a facilitator I do
not I do not work too hard I have not
chosen as a career supporting people
going through psychedelic experiences
but I wanted to develop a level of
confidence that if I were in an
environment where I was called upon to
handle the worst case scenario that I
would at least have a certain degree of
comfort and exposure to that but it's
really uncommon that you would get a lot
of repetitions with that that would in
fact mean that you would in some way be
manufacturing these terrible conditions
oh so one of the few ways to do it was
to volunteer at zendo where you get
these kind of redline cases and you get
put in the crisis tent over and over and
over and over and over again and we had
a really rich conversation about that
about this type of deliberate practice
with the edge cases that are nonetheless
really important to develop a degree of
comfort around and I think that you can
do it matically or non-locally you don't
have to do it specifically in the thing
so for example one of the beautiful
things that the e4l opened up to me and
Dan was the ability to just wear one
wave that we fell in love with this
offshore reef and we just it would just
mound up into this super steep ramp that
is kept on going and it was actually two
converging ramps and we called it ramps
and this wave was it was sort of like
the drop that you'd make surfing that
would last a second it would that drop
would last 45 to 60 seconds and a buddy
who who served at said we should call it
aneurysms because it felt like an
aneurysm that lasts for 60 seconds but
we did so many thousands of those waves
then it's like you get used to the
aneurysm and then the aneurysm becomes
mellow then it was just a mellow place
to be and then that then you translate
that over to foiling in unlike the
lightest most high performance board
possible the drop you might down you
make down a steep face before a bottom
turn we've just done so many of those
that lasted for so long these sections
that would have felt super critical to
us before
just don't anymore similar you can do
cold plunges so if you do if you're cold
plunging in 33 degree water your body's
gonna go into that same freakout
fight-or-flight place and then learning
to breathe through that come on the
other side I mean cold plunges are in a
non-local way a great way to train at
making steep drops surfing or foiling
you know it's controlling it or control
it may not even be controlling a panic
response but becoming familiar with the
physiological response to panic right on
some level and those people listening
obviously can't see what's going on here
but you have a you have a richness a
smorgasbord of cold plunge options here
and 33 degrees is is not a grand
exaggeration because I unplugged one of
the cold plunges a few days ago because
turning into an entire ice block so for
the last few days we've been getting
inside and being surrounded by ice and
the sea I think the idea of kind of
non-local practice applies also to what
what I was mentioning right because I've
done I've accompanied doctors on ER
rounds for similar reasons right to
become more comfortable with an
environment that seems out of control or
unpredictable and another option within
the realm of say psychedelic harm
reduction would be engaging or
facilitating in large breath workgroups
where you will have people whether it's
holotropic or something else respond and
really exaggerated outwardly expressive
ways in these groups you have to keep
them from safe flailing and hurting
themselves or hurting someone else how
do you what types of practice have
become more important to you if you're
looking back at your say competitive
career in chess and where your practice
of jujitsu what types of practice or
thematic practice have become more
important
have you learned to value more or less
does anything come to mind conceptual
practice thematic practice I think that
that for example building on what you
just said I would say that the tension
one feels as a chess player the buildup
of tension with both psychologically and
technically on what's happening between
the chess pieces is very similar to it
might be difficult for people of
visualizing people sitting on a chess
board and compared to like dropping down
big waves but it's very similar to the
feeling one has dropping down big waves
you feel it's the it you feel the
desperate urge to release the tension
and similar in cold water right and so
the the the path that I've worked with
so initially it's pain it's red alert
get me out of here then it's becoming at
peace in that pain and it's learning how
to enjoy it and so like the great chess
players like someone like Magnus Carlsen
one thing that's unique that fairly
unique about him is he seems to really
enjoy tension right and I've trained in
my I never got there as a chess player
but I have gotten there another thing
just learning to just completely love
chaos so the tension isn't isn't
grinding on you you're not a tectonic
plate moving toward eruption you're
you're getting stronger as the tension
builds and and that's something that I
think is beautiful to Train at something
like cold water is just something you
can replicate every day to do it the e4
will open that up and drops boiling
right so I think to answer your question
conceptual learning has been when you
learn a technique you're learning one
thing when you're learning a principle
that embodies a technique you might be
learning a thousand things and so
designing a learning process around the
meta this is part of the reason why I
think my approach into surfing and
foiling has looked so strange to
somebody's who are lifetime surfers
because I'm not approaching it
technically the tech I'm approaching I'm
working on internalizing certain core
concepts principles the techniques fall
within the tree beneath the principle
but so meta training I think would be
the most important answer to that
question you're also coming into foiling
with a huge disadvantage / advantage
which is you have not spent decades
surfing right right so you're looking at
things very differently and just to give
one example and as background before we
began recording this you let me you
encouraged me to read through a slack
channel that you have with your team
where you're bouncing different ideas
off of one another and their stress
testing your ideas also ask you to
clarify things define things and you
mentioned at one point frontside turns
not to get too deep in the weeds but
frontside turn different from backside
turn and then realizing that you could
practice that on an equal by just
effectively with correct me if I'm wrong
but what I read was kind of going in
circles yes spinning in super tight sir
and you're doing just hundreds and
thousands of repetitions that would be
impossible to replicate except over an
extremely law I mean weeks months whole
years years on a surfboard and so you
you were able to see that where I think
perhaps others might not certainly some
would but that struck me is a huge
advantage that you have that you're
seeing things with beginners eyes and
you're already technologically enabled
so you have just a greater buffet of
options I think it's really important
for me to be clear I'm just a beginner
in the surf and for worlds right I mean
most of the people who are foiling I've
been surfing for twenty or thirty years
their whole lives because foiling is is
super hard it's surfing much faster with
an extra vertical dimension it the
interesting thing about it is is I'm
learning how to surf and paddle surf
through foiling the lines that I can
draw foiling are much better than lines
that can draw paddle surfing and what's
fascinating is I went out surfing I'm
right now foiling you know six days a
week maybe in surfing paddle surfing one
day a week I went out paddle surfing
yesterday because the foil that the
swell dissipate a little bit it wasn't
great foil conditions where we go and I
am I was
Mays the breakthroughs I've made surfing
just from the for long breakthroughs
I've made over the past couple weeks
it's really interesting so I'm coming at
this in every ways in every way
backwards
I approached I'm taking on the art of
surfing and paddle surfing I started in
my late 30s not as a six year old kid
and so that also speaks to some of the
things that Dan and I who this is relate
to Dan as well things we need to do like
we haven't gone sideways forward like
been in a surf stance moving forward at
high speed sideways a very simple idea
right if you're a skateboarding or
you're surfing or snowboarding you're
like in a sideways posture you're going
forward very fast we haven't done that a
lot in our lives so things like the one
wheel which Dan and I both did and then
the e Foyle like that just gave us a
huge amount of reps and then the amount
of waves we've been able to take efiling
we've been learning about surfing waves
through those reps and so in your right
I think it's a disadvantage in a lot of
ways that we're coming on it so late but
it's also a wonderful advantage because
we're not socialized by any of the
assumptions that a lifetime surfer would
make similarly in like the Chinese
martial arts taking on the Chinese
martial arts there's lots of things that
Chinese martial artists who are lifetime
aficionados will not consider that
coming at it as an outsider from the
chess world I could take advantage of
similar in the Brazilian jiu-jitsu world
we could have conversations about those
I think we actually have spoken with
over the years but but all of these arts
have their blind spots let me just go
back just just finish the circle one
time because we began speaking about
this exploration I was doing with
Maurice roll over the chest in the
common root structure right between
false constructs so just to close that
loop I think that so what I'm exploring
now is that like so what was the the
essence of that that thing I was too
tight about with Maurice I was being a
bit a little bit to local and too tight
in the early stages of the learning
process of something which in that
moment was a chess opening a branch of
the knight of Sicilian I am explore I
was what about that word just a spell
for people Najdorf that night or from
mEagle naidu was it was a brilliant
chess player and a JD ORF and there's a
very Sicilian defense is a chess opening
this was a night or variation of the
Sicilian defense it was just sounds of
something from The Princess Bride
continued
okay um yes jazz openings have have
funny names sometimes but yeah so I was
so the interesting question is is that
tightness is is there a shared root
structure it relative to that tightness
in the learning process today and it for
you for me mm-hmm
right and I mean there was a moment
where Dan and I were whipping into a big
a big wave called called MA we called
mobs here where it's a left on Foyle he
was on a jet ski I was behind it and he
came you know he was whipping into it
and there's a big bear rock that bear
that just it gets sucked out and is
basically a big dry rock on the wippen
and it was interesting because this was
the in the first few days of us taking
on toast Oh foiling and in that moment
like I
there was a tightness in me right now we
come close to that rock all the time
efore ly we I think will be very
comfortable playing right there soon
Toph oily but in that moment I was in
the early stages of a learning process
and it was very similar because in that
moment there was an improvisational
nature to that moment it was playful it
was actually not such a big risk
relatives to what we do all the time but
there was there was a tightness in me
because I we were learning something new
technically in that moment I wanted to
work on the deconstruct of component
parts of tow foiling and then work on
like that kind of thing so I do think
that it's interesting for me to explore
is there some identity in the idea that
I need to deconstruct first similarly
questions like parallel learning
lateralization I would say one of my
biggest strengths as a learner has been
the ability to translate from previous
arts into current arts it's interesting
to invert that are there ways that might
be holding me back is the idea of
lateral izing or parallel learning
impeding my learning process in any way
so these are these are assumptions that
I might have that I might hold tightly I
don't know it's very interesting to take
our assumptions and examine them flip
them upside down rip them apart
may I ask you about one potentially
backwards approach that I want to know
more about yeah
specific to your notes in the slack
Channel and that is a quote that also
one of your team members asked you about
so the internal spirit is the teacher or
myself 20 years from now I'm most
interested in the last part of that we
could talk about the whole thing but
what does that mean or myself 20 years
from now yeah that came out of me a few
months ago and I was trying to explain
to a buddy of mine in the surf world
this bizarre way that that I'm
approaching this stuff because it looks
really strange to people sometimes and
and what I was saying was sort of in a
in a thematic way it's as if myself 20
years from now as my teacher and and
what I mean it first there's two ways of
looking at it one is that I know myself
decades into arts I don't know myself
decades into chess and into the martial
arts and so I have a feeling for what I
am like when I'm in the realm of
virtuosity within an art and so in a
sense that person is like that's a
beacon that I'm moving toward right and
I'm nowhere near that realm as a surfer
in a foiler I'm but but I've been there
and so so so qualitatively in terms of
some like abstract platonic realm of
quality there's that beacon for me and
there's the other part of it which is
that no one will know me better than
myself twenty years from now and if my
goal is unobstructed self expression or
self actualization within an art then
the person who is teaching me should be
the person who knows me most deeply and
that's my person twenty years from now
the person twenty years to now is also a
helpful visualization in in being the
person who would understand what my
false constructs are today and yesterday
and a year from now and it's very easy
to get stuck in the mindset we I didn't
know before but I I know today it
reminds me there was this funny moment
years ago when I was first studying Tai
Chi and I was in William CC Chen's Tai
Chi studio this was back in I think I
think it was 1988 1998 1999 and there
was this guy had been studying for
decades and he was telling a story and
he was sort of holding court within his
knowledge of wisdom within this domain
and he
said you know when I studied cha Chi for
a year I thought I knew what I was doing
and I thought I would really start to
understand it but after two years I
realized everything I thought after a
year it was wrong it was just wrong but
now I understood and then after four
years I realized everything I thought
after two years was wrong and he went on
with this story in this pattern but now
I understood then when after eight years
the same thing everything I thought that
for is was wrong and now I've been
training for 16 years and everything I
thought after eight eight years was
wrong but now I finally understand I
remember thinking at the time man you
got it but you didn't get it
like the point is you don't know now
either right after 16 years you've been
going through the repetition what about
after 32 years so I so for that
visualization is designed to help me
know that I don't know yeah right and
and which is so important it's so easy
to think that we were in the dark
yesterday but we're in the light today
but we're [ __ ] in the in the in the
dark today too so I have a question
about the self twenty years from now
because a follow-up question part of
what I enjoy about these these
conversations with the mics is that with
you know we get to hopefully edge into
some stuff that we haven't talked about
because we talk all the time and I don't
think I've ever told you about the piece
of writing I lost that came to me the
most and the piece of writing that I
lost was the following I was for some
reason maybe feeling under the weather
or had an injury something like that I
was unable to join some friends skiing
and I was very upset about this I love
skiing and I was sitting in a lodge
loved ski lodges so that's the upside
and there's beautiful fire so on got
some hot chocolate cuz that's what I do
when I'm feeling Moody and want to stuff
my emotions and a ski lodge and I had
paper and I wrote this this long story
about a guy aka young young Tim
wandering into ski lodge sitting down
and having this older gentleman 20 years
older gonna sit across the
a table near the fire by him and
striking up a conversation and I only
realized later this that this is very
close to a story by I think it's jorge
luis borges
but ended up being this surreal
interaction between my younger self and
my older self and asking my older self
for advice on all these various topics
over the course of a few hours of
sitting there in the ski lodge and I
looked at the advice after I had been
writing all this for five to ten pages
and the advice made sense a lot of the
advice seemed like very probably it
could be the advice that a 20 year older
self would give me with some detachment
from the emotions of the current
situation and somehow someway I ended up
losing it and that we ate bothers me to
this day because I thought it was there
was so much there that I felt was really
insightful and actionable and it's wild
that it came from the same head that had
created so much confusion around the
same situations so beautiful so you
rewrite it man
I so I have actually not rewritten it in
exactly that same way but I've asked
myself for instance there are a bunch of
decisions that I'm trying to make right
now what would my I'm 42 right now 47
year old or 50 year old self tell me to
do right now as it relates to these
decisions there's a lot less turbulence
right around a lot less kind of cloud
cover when looking at it with a bit of
detachment that way I'm curious if you
ever kind of take it that literally or
have tried to look at your current
decisions or situations through the lens
of an older self in that fashion
you know just quick aside before I go
there I think it's a really interesting
question to ask people what what like
how would your 20 year older self guide
you today because it gives you a window
into somebody's ability to perspective
take and to think conceptually in other
words like you think about the old David
Foster Wallace this is water
story of you know two fish are swimming
in the water and two young fish and an
older fish comeback comes by and says
how's the water boys and they look at
one another as they swim by and like
what the hell are you talking about
water right most people can't see the
water because they're just used to the
water but it's very different to
actually be able to see our mental
models our frame so people are usually
looking at the world through their
frames they're you know we can also
cultivate the ability to look through
the frame but also see the frame and and
I spend a lot of my life working on
examining the frame itself right I think
that you know years ago we did one of
these these chats together and I
described the drowning experience I had
where I made some errors in um in
breath-hold works one way to put it
right we've already gone there we don't
see this a lot but just just give that
give the the 30-second version oh you
can you the 30-second version is that I
was doing some wim HOF inspired
breath-hold work I made the mistake of
doing it during multiple lots of reps of
under water swims 50 metre swims at a
pool in New York City and on my like 8th
or 10th rep I blacked out in a bliss
state and I spent 4 minutes in the
bottom of the pool after blacking out
from oxygen deprivation
this old guy pulled me out and and which
I'm eternally grateful for and I
basically drowned all the doctors said
after 45 to 60 seconds I should have
been brain dead or dead but it was four
minutes on the bottom of the pool and
then my training saved me like also you
could say put me there but that's a
whole other conversation
there was a so that we've discussed that
whole experience at length we don't
think oh they're in depth but but I
think that that that inspired a version
of this this thinking and it led to a
lot of the life decisions that that I've
made and our family has made living life
with it today which is very much off the
grid because I emerge from that
experience just with I mean I I was
someone who filled with a lot of love
and an appreciation for doing what one
loves but that went into overdrive and I
just decided that I would devote my life
to living as fully and deeply and
beautiful as I possibly can helping
loved ones live is fully and deeply and
beautifully as they could and making as
large a positive impact in the world as
I could and that was just all that
mattered and I am and we have rooted our
life and changed everything so I think
that that that mortality experience and
and I am I mean that that was the most
powerful catalyst for that kind of
thinking and and I should just note that
thankfully I have not had that
experience but about a year ago at a
retreat group retreat there were a
number of writing exercises that we were
instructed to do and one of them was to
respond to a prompt and the prompt was
pretend as though or imagine that you
are going to die exactly two years from
today you will die in perfect health
just clock will run out two years from
today you will die what will you do in
the next two years what are the things
that you would do and I realize that's
somewhat different from having a
near-death experience and then
reprioritizing but it does apply a
certain pressure and a certain sense of
urgency that I think you would get from
either situation and that that prompt
and what I wrote afterwards gave me a
tremendous amount of clarity about
certain things that I want to do and
another prompt was if you were going to
die in two years in perfect health what
left undone what would you most regret
not doing so so similar question but
slightly different wording that also
provided me with a tremendous amount of
clarity about certain things that I
followed through so it can be simulated
in that way absolutely yeah I think that
you know I weave over the years
discussed this term firewalking
that I use for physiologically embodying
something we're trying to learn so for
example if you're training in the
martial arts and you overextend your arm
and you
get armboard and you're like elbow gets
broken or your shoulder gets ripped up
for example in a World Championship
you're less likely to overextend your
arm next time all right to say the least
but if you watch someone else do it on a
video it's hard to learn that lesson but
if you like if you learn how to
physiologically embody the experience
that you're watching someone else go
through or that you're thinking about
the abstract right then we can save
ourselves a huge amount of how does it
how does one do that or how might one do
that how have you or how have you
coached someone to do that effectively
whether it's chess jujitsu investing
otherwise well I think intense
visualization get it it's really
training at visualization which one can
do through meditative experience I think
biofeedback training is really useful to
help learn how to put yourself in a
different physiological States at will
because you can actually use biofeedback
to observe what state you're in if you
just don't sense it so quickly
introspectively harnessing triggers for
antenna I was with my with my wife and a
bunch of friends the other day and um I
haven't watched the Oscars and years but
the Oscars was on and Eminem's
performance of lose yourself came on and
I it's funny lose yourself was the song
that I used in the to my training camp
for the 2004 World Championships in so
for the three months of the last of
every day of training I listened to it
before every fight of the World
Championship in 2004 in between the
semies and the finals and in between the
finals in the sudden-death playoff when
I've been in the wild this state of my
life
that song is such a deeply [ __ ]
burned in trigger I was Mel I had my my
eight-year-old son in my lap we were
watching the Oscars my three-year-old
was sleeping on my other shoulder and
lose herself came on and my body was
ready to fight 15 dudes
it was unbelievable what happened to me
I had to just leave and I took a walk
for 10 minutes like unbelievable how
powerful triggers are whether it's all
factory triggers with smell or music
connecting triggers different
physiological things I'm not suggesting
that what one should should have
something that I mean that's that's a
pretty intense ones like the vaquita is
like yeah maturing candidate stuff
yeah exactly the guy I mean I was it was
kind of amazing to feel how powerful
that was so many years later just just
right there so I think that that
learning how to put your I mean learning
how to put yourself into an attained
intense physiological state through
visualization for example cold plunging
your body will go into an intense
physical physiological state you can
attach a trigger to that then you can go
into that kind of fight-or-flight state
if you choose to so for example one of
the things you do cold plunging is you
get into say freezing water and then you
learn to breathe yourself it takes a
while initially but then pretty quickly
into a state of calm like your heart
rate goes very fast you're
hyperventilating a little then you just
chill it out and then you're in a calm
state you can also choose not to go
there
you can choose to get in the water and
not breathe to that state of calm and
then you can exit in that state of alarm
and that can become a state that you
could use as a trigger for certain kinds
of visualization so there's lots of
things that you can do if you're
creative about firewalking what are some
of the ways that you build outside of
foiling because I know that's a main
focus so I have to kind of grab you by
the hair to pull you out of foiling but
and you do follow a lot what are other
ways that you've built feedback loops
into your life well feedback loops are
are everything I mean you you can it's
funny I was talking whoa
one of the funny things about my
conversations with Maurice because I
really left the chess world behind and
it was fascinating just talking to him
about how it's evolved so much and one
of the questions that I was asking him
is how present our world-class chess
players today to the networks of
cognitive biases and he said that that
what's interesting is that many of the
great chess players today actually don't
even know what cognitive biases are and
one of the reasons that they're able to
do that is because chess today you just
have such unlimited accurate feedback
loops because you've got computers that
are much stronger than humans analyzing
the position by your side so any
decisions you make you can look over and
see if it's right or wrong and the
computers are so strong that they're
gonna be right and so you can basically
have a feedback loop whenever you want
and so you just if you have unlimited
feedback loops and you're training six
eight hours a day you just learn to feel
when your thinking is good and when it's
bad so just to clarify it in other words
cognitive bias is right this is a we
won't go too broad but an example of
that would be something like sunk cost
fallacy right so players back in the day
would have some conceptual understanding
of how to define sunk cost fallacy what
that means but today it's more a
intuition built upon thousands and tens
of thousands and hundreds of thousands
of near immediate feedback loops right
so the way sunk cost fallacy could
operate consciously for a chess player
is that you're studying a chess position
you've invested twenty minutes into it
and you're starting to sense it might
you might be barking up the wrong tree
but you put so much time into it you
want to keep on going right or that
could just manifest without any
consciousness of the bias in just that
your thinking doesn't feel good or
you're in the moment you're thinking
starts to feel a little bit less present
or less on it then you just go the other
way right or like you can have a
confirmation bias where you're you you
can think okay right now am i or am I
not searching for proof of something
that I've for a decision I've already
reached right or you can just not be
subject to confirmation bias because
you've had it burned out of you by so
many reps of feedback loops just beating
the [ __ ] out of you whenever you get it
wrong right so in arts where you have
massive amounts of natural accurate
feedback loops you don't have to be as
conscious about these things on the
other inspection of something like
investing it's very very hard to have
accurate feedback loops because the
decisions you make today if you're a
long-term investor the students you make
today you might not actually see the
result of that decision for many years
and you could have had good process and
still a bad outcome where you could have
bad process still a good outcome so you
have to so it might not be an accurate
feedback loop even if you do have the
feedback loop and so in realms like that
you have to be really creative and I
would argue that a lot of what defines
the learning curve of someone in a field
like investing where accurate feedback
loops are few and far between
is how creative you are in creative in
in manifesting them for example you can
have somatic feedback loops you can use
biofeedback to understand when your
performance state
is at a high-level quality or a lower
level of quality what does it correlate
to physiologically exactly so when
you're thinking well what does that mean
what is the biofeedback saying and then
you're going to see a physical signature
what's the signature of those good
decisions right which we use biofeedback
for initially then we learn to learn
from about feedback had a sense how to
feel it right so a lot of what I you
know when I'm training people and like
elite mental performers a lot of what
we're doing is being extremely creative
in designing accurate feedback loops in
places where it's not so so I'm reeling
so you asked me about myself oh it's
it's I mean you told me not to speak
about foiling because but but it's
difficult was like that's what I'm going
on now
so like I'm training in paddle surfing
and foiling and so I mean I'm gonna kind
of swat that deflection side I mean
because that's what I'm all-in on yeah
right and so what I so I mean I have
I've learned that feedback works for me
sometimes and other times I don't want
it so for example I have a buddy who who
does drone footage of us once or twice a
week on a cadence relative to the swell
but also relative to where we are in the
learning process usually I all study
video very closely and then I'll spend
four or five days training without video
feedback at the thing that I'm working
on and then I'll then I'll have drone
footage again so I will have video
feedback at a pace that feels
appropriate to my learning process be
there sometimes you want I find that you
you want to internalize you want to work
on what you're feeling internally
without an external I then sometimes you
want the external I and I honor that I
really trust that similar to in for
example the in let's just say you're
training Brazilian jiu-jitsu and you've
got a tournament coming up your
repertory tightens right you it
condenses down to what you're best at
but then you have a period of time where
after the tournament where may say
you're not gonna compete for two months
you might have an experimental repertory
you're playing with things that by
definition you're not very you're not as
good at but that you're expanding your
you're investing in loss a little bit
you're getting beaten up by some people
who you couldn't beat up with your best
repertoire but you're working on things
so in that moment if you're studying
video in that period you might reject
what you're doing because it's not as
good as you can be you know so that's an
interesting
period just work on somatically dialing
in something and feeling your way into
something I think I just want to
underscore that because I think it's
really important and that is it's not
always true that more feedback is better
absolutely and if I look at a lot of the
best teachers in gymnastics in skiing
for instance they're very one of the
terms or one of the phrases that that
that I heard a lot in gymnastics was
like the first three wraps don't count
right because if someone's trying
something brand new their first few reps
you're gonna suck they're gonna be
terrible right but they're going if they
have a bit of awareness and other
techniques or other practices they're
going to be getting a feel for it over
those first few repetitions and if
you're just hitting them with 20
different sets of instructions every rep
it's gonna be counterproductive right
and I think that there's feedback that
you're internally generating based on
how you feel and how you observe you
look on video and then this feedback
that a coach or trainer might be giving
you for a coach or trainer to give you a
feedback they have to like for you to
let that feedback in in my view they
have to know you very deeply so there's
a lot of trainers for example who can't
get outside of their own conceptual
scheme so they tell you what you should
do based on what they would do or what
would work for them or they would want
to do if they were in your shoes in that
moment but that's very different for
what you need to do in your learning
process or you're ready to stretch for
in your learning process when I'm
working with people on a training
capacity you know I have ways of
observing my core partners in training
like professionally you know through
their journals through their brainstorms
through their biometrics through lots of
different things and and I will eyes
99.9% observation and I will might see
something that I would like to give
feedback on or that I think I might make
you know give some feedback I'm an all
observe it sometimes for weeks or months
or even years until the moment is right
or I will have a hypothesis that I'll
test and then I'll think about what
would be the way to explore this it
would be most helpful and not lock
somebody else up right so so much of
what most coaches that I observe live
with is their own ego pattern the ego
pattern in they're stuck in their
conceptual schemes but also they want to
have the egoic satisfaction of telling
you you're doing something wrong or or
or making you better but the great
coaches will actually coach without
someone even being aware that they've
been coached question for you on stress
testing your own thinking so I read the
slack channel which is comprised of
interactions mostly your sharing of
ideas and thoughts and then the asking
for clarification by your teammates and
who are employees how else do you stress
test your thinking or positions on
things do you have a proactive way of
doing that does it just happen naturally
in your interaction with various friends
because you have you have physically
somewhat isolated yourself right
how do you how do you think about stress
testing the integrity of your thinking
and positions yeah great question so I
mean Isaac aliy isolated myself as you
point out but also somewhat
technologically isolate I mean I'm not
on Instagram or Facebook or Twitter or
any of them stay off going I said stay
off yeah that's the game plan but I have
I have a really wonderful network of
close friends and thought partners
yourself included who I I am in dialog
with and who I really trusts and I don't
have a lot of dialogue with people who I
don't think highly of and so I mean for
example around what I'm working on
actively in my training process Dan
Caulfield who I'm you know we're out
there on the water for five hours a day
together
he knows me you know as intimately I
mean our friendship was born in fighting
one another for thousands of hours
literally that's a hell of a way to
begin a friendship as sparring partners
and then we still spar quite a bit out
there on the water and and and so like I
mean we're always stress testing things
together
Emily Kwok who is just an awesome woman
who's been my right-hand human for about
a decade she's a Brazilian jiu-jitsu
blackbelt women's world champion two
times over she's my chief of staff and
runs our whole operation
she's the boss of our whole thing and
she's I mean Emily one thing that Emily
is really brilliant at is is I mean we
have a shared consciousness she
understands me very deeply and she is
very good at pointing out to me when I'm
speaking in a shorthand that other
people aren't understanding so she
pushes me to deconstruct quite a bit for
our dialogue within the team and you
know more broadly is there a risk that
if you are of the hive mind together
that you have the same blind spots and
therefore our risk of missing flaws and
thinking worse yeah yeah I mean but I
all have dialogue but I have dialogue
with I mean I have I have I'm not sure
how many different channels of dialogue
open with with um you know I have
clients who I work with who are I think
some of the best thinkers in the world
when I'm talking about ideas with but I
think just a dig in to dig into your
point I think that absolutely yes and so
you need to have people in your
ecosystem who push against you and I in
our surf and foil ecosystem I mean it's
dan and I have this kind of a abstract
bizarre way of going about things and
almost everybody else who were in dialog
with we have a group of six of us who
are doing this again I mean three of
them think we're just completely crazy
loop the Jackson Pollock's of the
foiling we're pushing back on everything
we're doing relentlessly which is
awesome and I'm sure some things they're
absolutely right about III think that we
need to build pushback against us
resistance is a huge part of everything
we do now the one thing that makes it a
lot easier in a competitive discipline
like jujitsu for example or chess is
that if you get something wrong you get
your ass kicked
yeah right these arts where it's not so
iam the wave and kick your ass but but
in terms of other thing it's much more
abstract so there's a lot more room for
people to [ __ ] themselves but to
give a to give a current example for
myself and some of the conversations we
had we don't and are having we don't
have to get into the super specifics of
positions and stuff but as it relates to
investing right I would say something to
you as I did yesterday like here's a
statement I want to give you a statement
and I want you to try to tear it apart
right and I find that extremely helpful
right even if you happen to agree with
it right just to say I want you to try
to I'm gonna share my current
approach or what I'm thinking and I want
you to really try to tear it apart
because as someone with very powerful
CPU within your head I find that to be
really valuable for me to proactively
solicit that kind of feedback
I think cultivating a closed ecosystem
of people who you can trust to be honest
with you in their push back is really
important because a lot of people a lot
of people are surrounded by yes men and
yes women who will not do that do you
find and I mean this is such a maybe
cliched example but it's a good example
nonetheless I mean if you look at the
partnership between Buffett and Munger
right the the a lot of the discussion
I've seen about their partnership is how
complimentary and different their
thought processes are in some respects
in the investing world do you find as an
example that people who might
self-identify as value investors tend to
just hang out with other value investors
or are there people who are are some of
the better performers you meet do they
deliberately expose themselves to people
who have a different playbook to push at
the edges of their assumptions well
first of all it's important to note that
I don't spend time with like most with a
lot of investors like I spend time with
a very small group of investors who I
think are awesome people and who I think
approach things in a very unusual way so
I can talk about how these people who I
know very deeply operate around this
question but I don't but I think it's
pretty unusual I mean in my observation
the people who are really operating in a
world-class level who I'm aware of in
the investment world are engaging
surprisingly little with other investors
hmm they're separating themselves so
they're not susceptible to groupthink I
mean often their interactions with other
investors will be mostly as contra
indicators as opposed to indicators and
just to push back a little bit on I'm in
order to speak to the other side of what
you just said I agree wholeheartedly
that it's really important to stress
that's what we're doing
I think that is also something a little
bit crazy and messianic about certain
people who become really really great at
things and like I think about marcelo
garcia for example who we've talked
about a lot over the years who's my
partner in the school we own together in
New York the marcelo garcia jiu-jitsu
Academy he's nine time BJJ world
champion Abu Dhabi world champ I would
argue maybe I mean pound for pound
probably the greatest grappler to ever
live if he which is which is an opinion
a lot of people hold yeah for sure
if you just like YouTube or whatever
look at marcelo garcia i mean you'll be
check out the Marcelo team yeah he does
a lot of amazing amazing [ __ ] and what's
interesting is if you when Marcelo was
competing if you went with him to
competition and you felt him in training
camps you know I've been in a lot of
training camps with him and we've
sparred a lot in training camps and I
felt him in that in that physiological
state which is like you're fighting an
ape it's a really simple intelligent
just wild
I mean his lats are like hands in the
precision of how they close around your
neck it's pretty amazing
but there's a confidence that he goes
into things and it's the kind of thing
where you can walk into a room where no
one believes in you but yourself but
your self belief is so profound that
you're unstoppable and the way I relate
to that if you try to deconstruct it is
that like that kind of sense of
inevitability of success comes from
self-expression knowing that you're
playing your game you're playing your
game better than anyone else in the
world could and you build everything
around the uniqueness of who you are and
like but you there are moments I
remember when Marcelo was a zone when
Marcelo was in a man jealous he was
fighting on the sky Collison's is a just
brilliant brilliant fighter in his own
right and Carlos sounds went for a
wristlock and Marcelo pulled out and
then Marcelo put his hand right back
into a wrist lock look hollow sounds
right in the eye and let him try and
just stare them in the Iowa cross and
try to close a room and he just so he
didn't avoid the technique he just tried
to break this man by putting himself
into the thing and saying you will not
like you can't break me and you can
break someone by being unbreakable and
there's something about that kind of
self belief that is really powerful and
there's something about approaching
things in really unorthodox ways that
you don't really know if it's going to
work until it plays out I mean I'll give
you like a very basic much more simple
two example of that the idea that Dan
and me training in the e-file stuff was
going to translate over to the foil
stuff was something I had tremendous
confidence in but I mean pretty much
everyone who I spoke to in the surf and
foil world thought we were dead wrong
and thought we were just barking up the
wrong tree and if you look at the
footage side by side of those two
different tools I could see why someone
would conclude that for sure because
evil is way heavier you're on like a 70
pound instrument and you're you know
it's got a different dynamics but you're
foiling and you're falling fast and
you're getting tons of reps and the
Evora I would argue is much harder to
learn than a lighter foil and that it's
more high consequence if you could hit
by it's bad you're dealing with a
machine you can die lots of things but
but the thing is that it's but it's an
amazing creation and you get so many
more reps so learning on the thing you
just get I'm not sure if it would be
early on 100 X 500 X to the reps and so
if it might be harder to learn on some
level it's actually much easier to learn
because you can dial it in but the
belief that it will translate over comes
from sort of a deeply intuitive thing so
if I stress tested that with by talking
to other people in the foil world I
would have rejected it but I and and
what's interesting is that when when we
translated it over to being whipped in
on the lightest most high performance
board possible on foil it all translated
right over now I want to push back on
one thing do it and that and that is if
you had stress tested it you would have
rejected it I'm going to I'm gonna offer
that it's entirely possible for you get
to get a lot of contra indicating
feedback and still hold your position oh
for sure you're right and and I did yeah
I was getting a lot of that yeah so I
think you're right you just have to
handle the stress testing correctly now
the rest is I've I've read you put it in
your private journal those were reps
hidden in plain sight right where there
are reps hidden in plain sight like the
front side turns just by going in
circles as opposed to being on a wave at
all I just think about that actually
just like that front side turn think
it's such a funny idea like a front side
turn let's just say you're riding away
if you drop down the face of a wave and
then you do
turn so I mean you like turning on the
bottom of a wave like you go into the
flats in front of waving your bottom
turning back up to back up into the wave
like that we like a frontside turn
you're turning on the side you're facing
on the board right meaning like your
belly button is facing away from the
wave when you turn just for right now
your belly button is facing toward the
way oh it is that's a frontside that's a
frontside turn yeah that's confused so
so like I realized that my my cut backs
my backside turns on going on oh right
on a frontside wave I know it's a little
anyway my my frontside turns were
lacking so what was a I was able to do
on oil it's so ridiculous I put on a big
front wing and a very very small tail
wing which allows you to small tailing
allows you to maximize turn turn ability
and I just started to spin in circles
under power and I was using a folding
prop so if a wave came I could enter the
way of the proper folding into the wave
so in between sets I was spinning in
circles so I would be spinning in these
tight circles for two minutes at a time
just countless I mean if you were to add
up the amount of turn time that I got in
that one session - how many front side
turns you'd have to make I mean that I
don't know thousands and thousands and
thousands of waves of frontside turns
right then whenever a wave would come I
would just drop into it and work on that
same bottom account and then I go back
to spinning in circles I looked like a
total madman if anyone would have been
watching me they would it was like the
ultimate like like what the hell is this
you know doing Looney Tunes but I made
such huge growth in that moment can you
think of other places in other arts
whether it's chess BJJ push hands
investing anywhere where you might find
reps hidden in plain sight or a way to
do that type of deliberate practice that
is uncommon well I think I think yes
everywhere so we could get into a
technical discussion of reps hidden in
plain sight like the frontside turn
which is technical right which is I
think fairly obvious one I think that
where the really potent low-hanging
fruit you know hanging in plain sight
like lie are in the the thematic right
or in like breaking down the learning
process into the core principles or
themes we want to work on in doing reps
of those those are just invisible to
people in plain sight right so you mean
it
as an example maybe I'm pulling out the
wrong example but the learning the macro
from the micro say with the practicing
of the endgame in chess with just a
handful of pieces on the board would
that be an example where's that knob
yeah so that that would be an example of
that's a great example of Reps hidden in
plain sight where you're you're
basically setting King and pawn against
King to get a feel for the essence of
the King and the essence of the pond
then you're setting rook and bondings
and learning about the essence of the
rook so you're getting tons of reps of
the rook of the pond then you set a
chess tactics with rook and pawn tactics
and you're getting tons of reps of those
things so that's an example of of ways
that you can get reps of individual
pieces right so that's that's a great
example the way I would say of reps
hidden in plain sight when I'm thinking
about conceptual or thematic reps hidden
in plain sight it's more around I mean
for example one when we took on surfing
and foiling one of the things that that
we did that was strange was that you
know I was much more comfortable in big
waves than small waves initially because
I was comfortable with breath holds and
I was comfortable with intensity and
small waves in some ways a much more
technical and I just simply like I
hadn't and and so I made the decision
early on to to surf and foil big wave
bigger waves before I really took on
smaller waves it might be a strange idea
but but the kind of rep that I had to
get get was glide getting used to moving
fast forward sideways right so for
example the one wheel the e foil these
were getting tons of reps in just the in
in the idea of glide learn to feel what
glide was like right and just as an
example that might be parallel and I
please tell me if I'm not getting this
right but in terms of deconstructing and
taking one theme like that mmm so I am
visiting you with my girlfriend and
she's new to water in the in the
capacity of surfing paddling etc
and rather than take a bunch of surf
lessons which was the kind of knee-jerk
idea the both of us hands like oh yeah
that's what you do take some surf
lessons and your recommendation was to
consider taking out a boogie board and
just getting used to the sort of force
and dynamics of the wave movement yeah
when I watch how people approach surf
teaching I think for the most part it's
crazy that people for the most surfers
mostly teach people to surf bite is
going out and surfing like let's go out
and surf you know and they get their ass
kicked because you have to learn to read
the water how to pop up on the board how
to where to enter the where to enter a
wave then how to turn where to stand on
the board how to shift your weight on
all this stuff I mean in my opinion like
okay what we did with with your
girlfriend as we went out and pushed her
into a bunch of waves boogie board and
just learn to feel what glide was like
on the water also not traumatize her and
then learn to feel what different parts
of the wave the energy and watch the
wave in the last wave she got in her
first day was actually in the pocket of
a wave I pushed her in right where it
was breaking right Richard surfing and
she was so stoked and she had a great
positive first experience since she felt
glide and it was awesome as opposed to
like just getting super frustrated in
the beginning and I think the
deconstructing it is really important
you know an interesting example of
thematic deconstruction relative to reps
hidden in plain sight would be for
example this idea around being at peace
and chaos or being learning to be okay
internally or even to thrive internally
when your body is in alarm alright cuz
if you don't train at that then when
your body goes into alarm you're just
alarmed but if you do train at that for
example you can train at it like we
discussed through cold plunging or
different things that it controlled ways
of putting your body into that state and
breathing through it then you've trained
at that meta theme right of being at
peace in physiological alarm and then
working through it and then when you're
in a in a for example a surf moment
where you're in a total [ __ ] show then
you've trained at that most important
part of it how to breathe through it
right you've learned how to literally
technically breathe through the alarm
right as opposed to trying to do that
when you're also trying to read the
water and figure out if your body
and you're in the middle of a hold down
and you know you you've got one breath
you could take between the next set and
everything's freaked out you don't know
what the hell's going on right so I
think that that that's an example of how
to deconstruct things down to component
parts and work on them
and I think it's actually it simplifies
the learning process in a lot of ways
because then when you put it all
together you've learned the critical
component parts the thematic component
parts you know like reading the water I
mean that's something that I think
should be done independently just going
out to learn how to surf mm-hm
but very few to some do but very few
surf teachers actually work people with
people on reading the water when they're
not surfing yeah and the the best
teachers I've run into on water for
instance good friend of mine Kelly
Starrett incredible performance coach
physical therapists all-around hilarious
guy also former world class kayaker and
we spent time on Grand Canyon together
with his family and that's exactly what
he did before attempting anything
technical before learning any new skills
he's like I just want you to move with
me and I want you to watch the water and
he would explain it once somebody gets a
next set of Rapids and he go okay what
do you see where's the tongue where
would you go right it's hypothetical
before just throwing me in with 20 new
skills to try to juggle simultaneously
but that takes empathy as a coach yeah
he's a he's a is it he's an exceptional
exceptional coach yeah he's very good at
the Buddhist technique of expedient
means or liberabit of technique
depending on how its translated of
teaching of being aware of what the
student is ready to stretch for and
going there that's taking yourself
outside of your own conceptual scheme as
a teacher and understanding what the
student needs right I mean that's I
think that's at the various like
principle 101 as a teacher very few
people really internalize it yeah Kelly
and you are both very good also at
ensuring that the first few experiences
are at the very least non-threatening
right so that they may not be
orgiastic celebrations of joy but at the
very least they're not gonna be
traumatizing right he's very good at
that whether it's Olympic weightlifting
or kayaking on what can be very very
scary Rapids at different points in
assuring that the the first few
experiences as you're just getting a
toehold on the basic sensations of a new
skill are non traumatizing I've learned
that I think if some people in my past
might not say that was a core strength
we can let that one go for now well
we're uh we're coming up on a very
exciting afternoon here so I know we we
don't have too much too much time left
but I'd love to ask you maybe in closing
about Robert Keegan am I getting the
pronunciation of that name correct yeah
who is Robert key and why is he
interesting to you so our friend Graham
Duncan first turned me on to the Keegan
many years ago and I've read his work
but I've been in the last couple years
just becoming increasingly impressed
with certain core points that he's zoned
in on it he's just a brilliant adult
developmental psychologist and a lot of
his work is around that the transitions
in the human mind from an opportunistic
to a socialized to herself authoring to
a self transformative kind of mindset
and and if we just owned in mostly
around the transition between the
socialized mind in the South authored
mind which is yeah hold that thought may
I ask does Graham find this is he
focused on this mostly in the context of
talent acquisition or finding good
talent is this is this sort of part of
his filter and doing that
yes mm-hmm I think that that was how he
initially was drawn into it and I think
now it's just you know part of his
pistol lens yeah edge to lens it's one
of many very interesting lenses I don't
tend to have like think that one lenses
has got at all but I do well the thing
that I'm intrigued with with Keegan's
work which I have a huge amount of
respect for is the exploration of the
limitations of the socialized month
sometimes weekend is will somebody to be
able to perspective take to release
their perspective
someone else's perspective or the
ability to hold meant multiple mental
models that are competing with one
another and be at peace with that
tension between them right we can just
want people to do that but there are
certain developmental hurdles to that
and I think that that's an area that
Keegan has really explored brilliantly
and I do encourage people to read
Keegan's work how do you spell his last
name ke gan i
I think it's important to be
empathically present to the
developmental obstacles that we all
might have around what we can and cannot
do conceptually I mean it strikes me
that we're all blind it's just a matter
of a accepting that we're blind and
trying to figure out how we might be
blind or what we might be blind to
perhaps is a better way to put it Keegan
yeah and I agree and for those
interested Graham Graham and I had a
really fun conversation on the podcast
as well so I will create a short link to
that Graham's a brilliant dude dear
friend I love them and and one of I mean
he's the best mind I've ever run into in
the world around the hunt for talent and
the deconstruction of like potential
world-class talent out there in the
early stages best hair in the business
also absolutely severe fall envy of
Graham so for those people interesting
I'll create a short link to that
interview that conversation at tim dot
vlog ford / Graham gr aham Joshua
anything else you would like to to
mention discuss disabuse me of before we
wrap up nope
woodpecker is right now trying to put a
hole in my office I think that's a great
place to close ok so Josh working people
find you I feel like your answer is the
same as Laird Hamilton in the Pacific
Ocean yes well until next time thanks
for hanging in thanks better and
recording something for posterity to be
continued
hey man this was fun and everybody
listening for show notes for links to
everything Robert Keegan etc that we've
discussed
there's also incredible video that I'll
try
down of Maurice Ashley with me playing
chess hustlers which is just fantastic
entertainment in New York City so I will
link to that in the show notes just go
to teamed up log forward slash podcast
and until next time thank you listen hey
guys this is Tim again just a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me and would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun for the weekend and five
bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm I'll
spell out and just drop in if your email
you'll get the very next one and if you
sign up I hope you enjoyed this episode
of the Tim Ferriss shows brought to you
by athletic greens I get us all the time
if I could only take one Simplot what
would it be the answer is inevitably
athletic greens I view it as and a lot
of you now view it as all-in-one
nutritional insurance I recommended it
way back in 2010 in the 4-hour body and
I did not get paid to do so I've been
using it since before that they use it
in a lot of different ways I travel with
it to avoid getting sick or to help
mitigate the likelihood of getting sick
I take it in the morning to ensure
optimal performance and overall it
covers my bases if I can't get what I
need from whole food meals throughout
the rest of the day and if you want to
give athletic greens a try they're
offering a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I nearly always travel
with at least three or four of these one
those bags in other words if you buy
athletic greens as a first-time buyer
you now get
eluded time and extra $79 in free
product so check out the details at
athletic greens comm forward slash Tim
again that's athletic greens dot-com
forward slash Tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase this episode is
brought to you by helix sleep last year
I focused on dramatically improving a
few things surprise surprise
most notably the quality of my sleep
which seems to affect just about
everything this led me to revisit you
name it my daily routine morning routine
exercise diet all the way to what I
slept on and I ended up getting all new
beds here in Austin Texas including
mattresses from helix Slavin helix has
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
hot sleep or cold sleeper are you like
plush you like firm with helix there's
no more guessing or confusion just go to
helix sleep calm forward-slash Tim take
their two minutes sleep quiz and they'll
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life that is
their promise for couples helix can even
split the mattress down the middle
providing individual support needs and
feel preferences for each side they have
a 10 year warranty and you can test
drive your mattress for a 100 nights
risk-free right now helix is offering up
to 125 dollars off of all mattress
orders check it out get up to 125 off at
helix sleep calm phone / Tim that's
helix sleep calm 4 / Tim for 125 dollars
off your mattress order tickle ik helix
sleep comp forward slash temp
[Applause]